is bang and they're right there's
multiple Footsteps in there are you
telling me you're grabbing tissue
[Music]
people what's good what's good you asked
and asked and asked and we listened and
we listened and we listened and we
listened and we listened and we made it
happen for you guys
exclusively for our cult babies The Log
Cabin tour has arrived 2023 is going to
go off guys come and see your boys live
up and down the UK it's going to be out
of this world we're gonna have games
we're gonna drink we're gonna hold a
wine relax we're gonna have a laugh guys
everything that you love about the
podcast come and experience it live with
us yep
and let's run through the dates okay
let's right guys pay attention it's time
for the dates and the cities first up we
have leads Leeds Academy we will be
there on the 4th of May and now we're
coming down to Central London Hackney
Empire we'll be there on the 11th of May
then we're going to take a little bit of
a break we're gonna rest and recover
yeah and then we're shooting down to
Bristol sent George's Bristol we'll be
there on the 7th of September not May
September remember that and then we're
going up up up Manchester 0161 Manny on
the map O2 Manchester Academy we'll be
there on the 9th of September bromies
yeah Birmingham Midlands team Aston man
oh one two one
I want two one yeah we'll be in the
Birmingham O2 Academy the 14th of
September right guys see you there yeah
love you everything's gonna be blessed
pay attention to what I say right now
okay if you are on patreon if you were a
cult baby through and through on patreon
your tickets are coming out on Wednesday
February 1st be there be ready Wednesday
Feb first your tickets are coming out
General tickets are coming out on Friday
the 3rd okay
Wednesday and Friday yeah man cult
babies unite The Log Cabin tour is here
we cannot wait to see you coming out and
have a good time it's going to be
nothing but vibes
see you there
guys it's that time again
intro question of the week
but that's actually the most Butters
noise
question of the week this week guys is
what's the one thing you do so what's
the one thing you would do if you knew
you wouldn't get caught as per usual
dripping off the cheek juicy house
answers
so I'm just going to read them off
what's the one thing you do if you
wouldn't get caught yeah do you have an
answer do I have an answer uh what's the
one thing I do if I knew I wasn't going
to get caught
your face
um
nah bro
this big big huge let's not do
experience
don't TMZ let me just read your question
bro there's so many different spots were
hilarious all right anyway let's go
kidnap my ex tie him to a chair and give
him endless paper cuts for hours
paper cuts wow that's like um there's a
there's a a Chinese torture technique
what's it called it's a different thing
no what well you took your feet no
[Music]
nah bro
it's called I can't remember what it's
called but it's like the translation is
like death of a Thousand Cuts
they put like minuscule Cuts
thousands and thousands of thousands of
cuts you just bleed out your skin
literally like folds over Jesus that's
scary that's very scary so she'd kidnap
her ex and just give him paper cups
paper cuts paper cuts eggs you know just
let him live his life oh bro the amount
of bitter people on this thing all right
I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready
I'm ready
cheat on my man with his entire
friendship group
get away with it I would cheat on him
with his all his boys friendship group
wow
take my ex's newborn baby just to
satisfy my knee to see him in pain
brother
swear just to see him in pain
sleep with my opposite sister
that is treacherous
that's treacherous
wow stop taking the pill and have
another baby my husband keeps saying no
more
stop this is wild this brother it's wild
bro my husband keeps saying no more no
more no more she's like please she's
begging for her she's literally gagging
for it I want to you now give me another
you and he's like we can't afford this
really can't afford this and we don't
have the space what more do you want
she's like say less
that's what she said yeah say the less
cool
eat some damn cookies I'm done with this
diet I don't care what my boyfriend
thinks
no I was gonna pass out I took my breath
away
I don't care what my boyfriend thinks
I'm done with this yeah yeah to be fair
it was one of those ones when I read
that because I'm somewhat dying I read
that I was like
I know how she feels bro I know exactly
boring now I want sweets yeah yeah and
sugar I need sugar all the sugar yeah
yeah this is silly if he doesn't love me
fat he actually doesn't love him he
doesn't love me period yeah clearly
you're not the man for me yeah so I need
someone else yeah that's what exactly
someone else that's exactly what she's
saying
um tell that girl that my brother was
cheating on her with two of her best
friends
tell that girl you know that girl trip
the child that's screaming and running
around in the restaurant
100 facts I would do that facts bro 100
castrate my baby dad and force feed them
to his [__] who will be swiftly
uppercutted for her absolute cheek
okay
what
wow cheek yeah this is Bonkers oh
everyone would say like rob bank since I
was like yeah it's funny boring Sam came
around to cut my hair yesterday and he
was like oh
um
I saw the the question thing yeah and I
was like I don't see it so it's cool and
he was like yeah
he was like yeah he told me what the
question was and um he's like yeah I put
I'll rob a bank and as soon as I put
that I thought I'd post it if one more
person let's drop him thanks
I was howling boring bro shut up about
Robert bank that's basic boring Bro
you've got everything else to do you
want to rub a bang yeah you can triple
you and you're busy robbing banks boring
be imaginative yeah yeah yeah send
anonymous letters to my ex's wife
telling her he sleep telling her he
sleeps with all of his Realtors
damn yeah bro I mean if they're
Anonymous why can't you get away with it
do it then if you're bad thanks do it if
you want to do it so much facts because
he's getting away with it now so
literally
tell the police that my ex's Insanity
plea was all a lie send that boy to jail
slap a Mill's ass in the gym while she's
doing RDL
all she's doing oh wow say let's say
let's run it back what's the one thing
you do if you knew you wouldn't get
caught I would put bitters in my
children's juice
you know how disgusting that would be
I bet the yeah what people do to their
kids would be mad oh yeah facts facts
yep also I didn't write these down but
the amount of girls that want to see a
train run on them really
insane
I was like it was I'm fine I'm scrolling
through school I'm just singing train
train train train train I've seen Emoji
train train train
my boyfriend's Never Gonna want to do it
I want both of them in me I'm like raw
yeah the energy that's going inside my
body right now is mad really
trains bro
they just want it together died no
that's
that's why I couldn't believe it bro say
less I couldn't believe it that's juicy
that's juicy I want to know every single
one has said it bro because it's mad to
me because obviously I do these
questions every week right and I can
obviously see the pictures yeah yeah if
I see a buff reply yeah just believe I'm
clicking on your page I need to see if
you're private or not
it's hilarious bro it's hilarious to me
oh my days oh God all right running back
what's the one thing you do if you never
get caught I'd register as disabled get
my own blue badge and then Park like an
absolute selfish prick
hundred percent someone needs to start
doing up blue badges on the black market
I will pay through the nose for a blue
batch because you literally park
anywhere I've seen these man parking
double yellows
sorry I've seen it they do what they won
I've never seen that I've done it once
yeah because they're they're it's a risk
thing in it because if you're the
parking attendant yeah you're like yeah
blue badge yeah you might because if you
might have needed yeah if you get caught
putting that ticket on there and they
come out in the in the woods
and it's like you have to look them in
the eye and be like bro
and they're like wow
that's where the terrorist was hilarious
what did that that's two jokes
um
get barebacks by my ex's dad he's such a
sore
oh way bro these women are on stop oh if
they could never get caught these women
are on crudders yeah 100 100 percent
tell my ex-mother-in-law that her son is
actually into men and was only after
women for the money
what does that mean
initially wow
sleep with my sleep with my ghost sister
apparently she's a she's dirty in the
sack and a solid seven out of ten mine's
a five out of ten at a best
brother that's one thing you can't hear
as especially if you're a young man as a
young man you can't hear that your girl
sisters are free
you can't hear that
oh no you can't because you're spending
time in that yard you're spending time
and she oh your girl's gas oh you're
spending so much time with me lately I'd
love to see you blah meanwhile you're
just waiting for the sister to come home
yeah when when is Sherry here when is
she coming home yeah like where's she
been she was like oh she's seeing some
guy and you're like [__] yeah you're
livid you just look at the time my
brother's clapping cheeks
oh I heard she's a super freak oh that's
naughty oh it is I wouldn't be able to
handle that
it is
become a therapist and that emotionally
blackmail my patients into doing what I
want since I know their triggers
they're triggers yeah
wow it's dark
go to a Magic Mike show I know it's a
ram but I want to see them dicks
bro
funny that's weird no it's Haram but I
want to see though I want to see that
direct debit one penny from everyone in
the world once a month that's pretty
smart yeah that's pretty yeah yeah yeah
slap the living Christ out of a customer
that asked to speak to my manager facts
factual fat ass every time can I speak
to your manager Bang
ers
bang bang ask me again I dare you
if I'm gonna take two steps back fam ask
me again
no
that's so jokes
oh my God ask me again I got a couple
more
push my ex in front of a bus and then be
his nurse oh
then be his nurse wow I want to hurt you
and heal you I want to hurt you and love
me love me because this is all I see I'm
here I'm helping you there's no one else
here but me
yeah
bang up a proper cheeky old person or an
old racist who deserves it Jesus but
yeah that was the last one wow a lot of
them were so either basic or so graphic
I couldn't yeah I couldn't slap them in
I I bet they were graphic bro graphic
okay yeah yeah people are twisted bro
people are twisted yeah I could have put
it jeez okay
um that training spun me I don't think
you understand bro a man said I was
going to see train train emoji
they wanted gal just want it it's mad to
me one of them literally put I know my
husband wouldn't want this but I need
both of them in me who's them bam yeah I
couldn't repost it I want both of them
in who's them
he doesn't like to share
Jesus
Jesus yeah bro I was like wow that's
annoying that is wow that's not it oh
oh that's crazy that's crazy the thing
is this it's all like it's painted here
but like unless I'm up first I don't
want to hear it that's the thing as well
like I'm thinking oh no you're not
United and then she's like all right
gang if you think it's so naughty trains
human face run a train on me and I'm
like well
[Music]
hold on that's disgusting
yeah I'm all right I mean if I'm up
first then maybe yeah yeah but no yeah
yeah no no no no no no especially that
being third or fourth like um we were
talking about that chick that was
um that did up the whole Sun's
um Team yeah the basketball team
basketball team yeah yeah yeah talk
about it yeah you couldn't you couldn't
attack me in fourth yeah because I'm
like well we've got loads in it yeah
literally got loads inside of it bro no
yeah disgraceful and she's not even
bothered anymore oh yeah she's just here
yeah she just feels obligated yeah she
feels not here bro yeah yeah yeah she's
not here she's not present yeah yeah
she's just about she just feels
obligated at this point she's like come
on in Nasi nah that's just not and I'm
sexy and I'm just like it's my turn
you're just waiting on the side I was
waiting for your turn no yeah yeah yeah
it's never that's dead
um okay cool right
so guys welcome back welcome back thank
you for joining us again on this
beautiful beautiful Monday
um obviously as always guys if you want
to officially join the cult babies here
with your cult daddies you need to head
on over to patreon.com forward slash
shits and gigs and that's going to give
you an episode every single Thursday if
you like the Mondays hop on over and
enjoy the Thursday if you like binge in
the episodes we've got three years worth
of episodes that you can bench and if
you'd like to be part of a community we
have our fabulous Discord Channel where
everyone gets involved uh and then we
have the once a month Zoom meeting as
well if you really want to if you really
want to have a chat with your boys if
you're really bad about it then you can
jump on the zoom call as well
um
that guys are going to cost you a minor
minor minor three pound a month minor
10p a day you need to run the P to S and
G guys to join the cold babies once and
for all
um if you are watching us on YouTube
please subscribe to the channel it would
mean a lot to us and if you are
listening please please please please
please please please leave a nice review
uh it helps us on those charts it helps
us spread the word it helps us uh more
than you can possibly imagine so please
guys follow the channel and uh leave a
nice review before we get into the fun
fact right what I'm going to do is I'm
going to do this for the next few weeks
right okay so
I was listening to do you know who Jason
is Jay Shetty nah so Jason is like a
positivity kind of like Guru lifestyle
coach kind of guy okay
here's a podcast called on purpose I
think it's another podcast with one of
his boys as well but
um he has a super like uh a very big
like lifestyle podcast
um and he says some positive [__] okay
and he does some like self-development
[__] and he's a cool guy or Nice Guy
um not a lot of men but nice guys
podcast is good yeah anyway he has a
habit right
of
doing these very Grandy when he has a
guest on his podcast he does these very
grandiose introductions and like he
really goes deep into introduction
introducing the person okay and
sometimes I'm not gonna lie sometimes
he'll have a guest on there that I'm not
really interested in listening to but I
just want to hear how he introduces them
ah interesting okay and he had Kevin
Hart on the other weekend he had this
like big long introduction for Kevin
Hart and you're like damn bro yeah and
it makes you can tell the guests after
they do the introduction you can tell
the guest is always gas to be there yeah
yeah wow this guy cares yeah he [__]
cares okay
um so
when we do have guests I'm going to make
an effort to do a good introduction but
in the meantime I've decided for this
week and the next following weeks I'm
going to introduce you guys as we do the
introduction okay I'm gonna pick
uh one of the guys in here every week
for the next few weeks okay and do an
introduction okay okay okay I'm not
gonna pick you today okay well randomly
I'm gonna start on the back foot I'm
gonna I'm gonna start with Ellis okay
I'm gonna start with Ellis Ellis is like
what the [__] yeah yeah so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to introduce
even though it's not on camera I'm going
to introduce Ellis to the audience to
the YouTube yeah to the culture yeah
right so what can I say about Ellis yeah
so guys if you don't know
this is the Ellis introduction right
yeah yeah so guys if you don't know
Alice is our editor and this has been
yeah slash videographer videographer
slash creative director yeah yeah yeah
slash yeah graphic designer photographer
he's a man of many talents right and um
and this has been with us for a couple
years now and the the way we first met
Ellis was that Ellis we would
um we just released our First Merch
right indeed yeah so we just released
our first uh did our First Merch launch
um very very basic half years ago yeah
bro very basic designs and we get a DM
on Twitter one day and it's from Ellis
and Ellis uh messaged us and it was just
like a graphic design I can't even
remember what was the tagline that you
used I can't remember
always find the funny only the only the
ogs will remember that tagline wow that
was our OG tagline that SMG used to use
all the time always find the funny that
was our Mantra so Ella sent us this uh
graphic design tagline and I was like oh
hey guys big fan of the show uh I
drafted this up feel free to use it if
you want uh before I send it over and it
looked Peg so when the second launch
came around
um if you ever deciding what we're going
to do for the second launch and we were
like ah why don't we message Ellis who
did that sick uh always find the funny
design and see if he wants to do a few
more for us so we got in contact uh had
a call Ellis designed into that match
for us the merch did well yeah season
two match drop so when season three came
around no-brainer no-brainer chop this
up for us he did another we did another
successful launch everything was going
well Alice is slowly progressed into the
part of the team and then when we were
looking for an editor we put a post out
on Instagram and Ellis jumped in and
said ah
I edit as well
um if you guys are interested and we
were like dang that makes life super
easy yeah yeah you don't need to vet
anyone don't need to vet anyone cool so
me and Ellis had a cool
give an understanding of what we're
looking for
and lo and behold is very receptive guy
he does well at his job he takes on
criticism very very well and he's
passionate about everything he does and
he works in an efficient and timely
manner so when the time came to move
everyone onto full-time payrolls Alice
was obviously a no-brainer to come on
board full-time and uh Edison I sat down
uh a few months ago on the phone and
decided what his journey with the
company would look like uh if he was
interested obviously jumped to the
opportunity and now Ellis Is With Us
full time and he's doing an insanely
good job and he's yeah man he he quit
his he managed to quit his shitty job
um what was he doing again restauranting
kitchen or restaurant or something like
that
yeah
I mean Chef is shitty to be fair yeah
get back
but yeah
queer's Hospitality job to come and work
with us full-time and hasn't looked back
since and he's doing an incredibly good
job and um yeah man guys welcome Ellis
Ellis
[Applause]
I like that I like that I like that cool
man that was really cool so guys let
that be a lesson to you if you if
there's people that you're interested in
those things that you're interested in
just take a shot in the dark just take a
shot in the dark because if Ellis had
never sent us that thing in the first
place then he won't be here right now
very true
um very true so yeah take a shot in the
dark you never know where it might lead
um but anyway that's our introduction
before we carry on guys well before we
carry on As We Carry On Fire Lord Flags
is going to hit us with the fun fact of
the day so you may have seen this but
obviously
um The Last of Us is the main thing
right now so Last of Us zombie fungus is
real it's a real parasite that actually
takes hold of and takes hold of and
zombie fires small insects have you seen
that oh of course everyone's been
sending it nine times a day every day
I've not read it it's the first time I'm
gonna read the whole thing properly all
right so the video game inspired um hit
zombie apocalypse show The Last of Us
draws its inspiration from our own
reality and ecology
the show's fatal fungus exists
throughout nature
the creator has said that he was
inspired to create the 2013 game after
watching a nature documentary about the
real life
how do you say the core deceps the
cordyceps is the same cordyceps due to
the insects and what cordyceps due to
Insects sorry
it's the fungus that burrows its way
into the insects insects mind and
continuous and completely Alters their
behavior
and you know right away the idea popped
in our heads like what if it jumped into
humans
um could that cause you
because you could I think they wrote
that wrong because you could imagine oh
yeah of course you could imagine the um
this fate would be more than death or
worse than death rather
that your mind is still out there but
there's something else controlling your
body
only a certain type of cordyceps known
as I'm not reading that fungi something
um has the capability of let me actually
try and read that opio or opio cordyceps
fun guy that's easy
um has the capabilities of
um for a hostile takeover of a specific
insect within the nearby
environment out of the estimated 600
fungi only 35 of them have the zombie
making abilities
but yeah this is this is what the thing
looks like it looks somewhat similar to
the face thing in episode two yeah bro
so yeah that's that's actually mad that
um because obviously if you pull it back
to episode one
um it was like 1960s throwback where
they said all this fungus stuff oh fam I
knew I wasn't I was never surprised when
people started sending me saying this
thing is real I wasn't surprised in the
first place because that little 1960s
thing the way they were talking in depth
I was like that has to be real yeah that
actually has to be real there's no way
they've made that up for this show
because that all for the game because
that's that's too specific yeah it's way
too in-depth yeah yeah the science
behind it yeah sounds plausible and it's
crazy because it's one of those it makes
people think because obviously there's
this like second wave of flu that's been
happening this past what couple months
maybe and obviously when you when you
watch the show
um present days 2023. yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah 2023 now so it's like are they
trying to make us think are they trying
to hint are they trying it's one of them
ones but yeah
um that was a little fun yeah it's cool
bro and then the fact that like all it
the only thing in the game the the only
thing in the show slash game or whatever
that stopped them from
coming into humans was that they can't
survive at the temperature of humans and
then he was like and they have no reason
to ever to be able to survive he's like
unless the Earth gets hotter yeah yeah
and I've only read that that sentence
right there in episode one locked me in
because I was like oh that's today
that's right now that's literally today
um so Peng very very paying yeah it's
crazy so hopefully that doesn't Bang
I can't yeah because it can't sounds
terrifying come on yeah it can't um
right so we might as well transition
straight from that into Last of Us yeah
so episode two
immediate thoughts
thought I liked the way it went from so
much like not chaos in episode one but
like a lot of like drama dramatic scenes
in episode one so like a smoother
transition before I got to the end of
episode two like I like the storytelling
on of everything of how their Journey
went yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but it was
the chilling parts were chilling bro oh
bro V was it episode one was it episode
two episode one episode two it was
episode two the maddest and I felt like
the most like impactful scene for me was
when
um
Joel was talking to the to his chick
right and she had realized that um she'd
been bitten
and then she was like you have to go you
have to go and he was just standing
there
and just turn and grab the girl and dick
he didn't get back I sat down when I saw
that
he just grabbed her and dipped and she
screamed get off me yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah we have to go let's go it's
literally a wrap there's no looking back
he's mad because he had to process all
of that in five seconds yeah yeah yeah
yeah this is I'm never gonna see her I'm
never gonna see her and these men are
gonna break down the store any second
now he just took three deep breaths
grabbed her and dipped yes it was you're
a man he stays being a man bro you're a
man yeah he stays being a man because I
wouldn't know what to do
I wouldn't know what to do
before we before I continue thoughts
um yeah the episode was Pang yeah
this mushroom lips at the end oh lips
God I don't care how many times I've
been bit yeah oh Panic you're not
putting your your fungus tongue in my
mouth
terrify you yeah yeah if you had
terrified you just accepted she just
widened her eyes and kept trying to do
this thing I wouldn't push him back
you're not putting out my mouth I feel
like I felt like it was the smartest
thing to do because they can't see
they're here yeah um so it was one of
those ones where obviously when she was
flicking it that's what brought my man's
attention towards her so I felt like if
she had fought him
she wouldn't have had time to flick the
um the lighter because all the other
ones would approach how to surround her
so I feel like that's why she's just
yeah maybe yeah she knew that she didn't
wanna
turn into one of them and then cause
Havoc so she was like I need to just
dump you and accept what's happening
right Lord bro good Lord the whole thing
was Butters oh yeah when they got into
that was it the like the museum or the
museum with the blind ones in there
the thing they sent me was the fact that
like usually in his things and this is
obviously the premise that they set in
there is that one shot on the head these
things are done yeah yeah you just need
to hit him in the head yeah but these
things yeah yeah it was the Buddhas were
pinging off yeah right here and here and
I was like oh it's not going down
it's too scary and then I think I don't
know when it's happening but they got
that boss coming out soon
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
gonna be mad yeah that will be I don't
think I'm ready for that episode yeah
neither am I the yeah it's a very very
very pink show it's
I'm annoyed because I I somewhat agree
with you in the fact that it's going to
be the best show of the year but we're
in we're in January or February now
um but it's like it's a piss tick to say
it yeah yeah it's a piston say but it's
[__] fantastic yeah it's so good bro
um and what was I gonna say one thing
let's watch it together not to watch it
together but let's try and watch at the
same time as well I'm hearing this
Korean show on Netflix the physical
stuff yeah oh physical 100 yeah you saw
the trailer the other day yeah oh my God
bro it looks oh my God there's only two
or three episodes yeah all right we'll
watch it we'll bang out this is one of
them ones where it comes out weekly so
exactly so that's why I was waiting okay
the other day yeah I said you man are
beasts yeah yeah beasts bro yeah
oh some of the challenges yeah he's
gonna have to scrap for a ball until the
time runs out nah Fam I'm watching it
tonight bro it's it's real physical yeah
yeah it's real physical yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I ain't got the lungs for it I
wouldn't survive either I wouldn't
survive in that no no I only saw two
seconds on the trailer when they're
hanging on the Ting oh and they're like
this yeah
I wouldn't last yeah
um but yeah physical 100 that's gonna be
the new thing all right I'm hearing it's
good I'm not surprised I'm not surprised
each episode is an hour I'm not
surprised obviously yes say less that's
me tonight yes
yes sleep say less that's me tonight
physical 100
Jesus and when I was first sorry I
thought I don't know why I I when I
first saw it I thought it was a Japanese
thing okay probably because of like
Ninja Warriors
and then when I found out it was Korean
I was like I know it's gone because they
have no horsepower don't care about it
Koreans don't care about life and they
don't miss they don't they definitely
don't miss when it comes to production
they don't miss they don't miss bro so I
was like I was gonna bang facts why I'm
Koreans I thought you were gonna say
because there is another show that I've
added to my watch list I can't remember
the name I need to find is it the AI
thing no it's it's anime but it's an
anthology anime like Black Mirror but
it's a horror thing oh
[Music]
but it's scary looking and it's guys I
need to find it so you guys can have
context of what the show is called
um is it called like a hundred something
something like that because that's what
I thought you want to talk about myself
yeah it's called Japanese tales of the
um my car bed this thing
yes bro I'm not watching yes it looks
too scary I've heard it's good oh really
I've heard it's good God so yeah let's
get added to my list oh my God and the
fact that you just said is like it's not
episodic it's just different yes and
stuff Anthology bro right guys the
holidays went by so quickly they have
been in gone but did you remember to
take care of your package with the best
tools for the job the Platinum package
from manscape is the all-encompassing
package that every guy needs in their
life to make each and every day just a
little more special the headliner in
this package is the lawnmower 4.0 and
the trimmer has the Advanced Skin safe
technology to reduce cuts and Nicks on
your delicate Parts your boys here can
vouch for the manscape products uh as we
use them weekly facts and um if you want
to get involved guys all you need to do
is use the exclusive offer
which is going over to masgate.com and
use the code s n g Sierra November Golf
and that's going to give you 20 off plus
free shipping guys get involved today
that's massgate.com sng
20 off free shipping let's get back to
the episode okay
cool Right Moving On
you've got a question for me I do have a
question for you
um but before we get into that question
I have started watching kaleidoscope and
I am watching it in order because I'm
not dealing with all this malark random
ship
um and
knowing the fact that I know I'm not
going to watch it in a random order I
actually like the show yeah it's not bad
actually do you know what I actually
found out apparently Netflix mixes up
the order for you
that's what my brother said I don't know
I don't know if this is vetted no I
can't be bro I'm watching an order
what do you mean so what are you letting
it when it says next episode you're
letting it carry on right yeah so do you
know what you've been watching it in
because I remember I I kept a note of it
so I might still have it ours might be
different oh yeah in fact mine's an
order mine is not doing what you've just
said mine went from green yellow Violet
and that's how it's come up on the tick
yeah yeah because mine went yellow green
blue orange and I watched it exactly
like that stop it yeah yeah yeah I
thought you meant also everyone's order
is different yeah oh okay wait what was
your order yellow green
yellow first green blue orange oh my see
I've only watched three mine was green
first green yellow Violet now I've never
seen Violet nah
yeah that's good that's a good episode
there's a throwback it's a good episode
okay so let's say that oh maybe it's 24
years ago yes okay I have seen that I
just didn't add it to the notes oh okay
okay okay okay oh damn damn okay that's
annoying yeah that's annoying damn yeah
Netflix played us yeah the Netflix
Netflix actually played us for Trump um
and one more random thing we're going to
the next thing um Demon Slayer Mogan
train is on Netflix now I saw that yeah
but it's broken down into episodes oh
they've done an episode so seven
episodes so it feels like it's longer
than a movie okay it's two hours okay so
yeah guys watch if you've never watched
it watch it stop
um but yeah right question for you
um question for James right
how much
would you
um how much would you ask for to go on
naked attraction and be a part of the
lineup
how much would I ask for because they
asked me to go on it did I tell you
maybe you did maybe last year sometime
some chick DM me asking me to go on it
maybe you did
um
how much would I ask for to go on naked
attraction before you answer premise
guys that for those for those that don't
know what naked attraction is there's a
TV show in the UK I believe it's only in
the UK
um it's kind of like a dating show but
the jig is like let's say I'm looking
for gal so there'll be six girls
um lined up but I can't see any of them
they're all like um covered they're like
there's like blinds in front of them
yeah every question or so that I ask
whatever it reveals part of their bodies
more and more and more and I select who
I want to keep and who I want to dump
and they're literally naked yeah they're
awesome naked yes there's nothing okay
before we get into this yeah there's
nothing uglier than a naked person
apparently
because
when I watch it I'm like yeah
so yuck every time I'm just like yeah
bro never
um so how much would I apparently they
had like some fat wood on there that's
the reason why I asked you guys I saw
that pop up but I was like there was not
much information about that so I was
like whatever oh it made me think oh how
much was it because I know you know the
show for me to go on there they'd have
to pay me like
how warm is the studio
it's like this it's like our room it's
like this kind of chilly in here yeah
you'd have to pay me
ah
maybe like 150 150 bucks yeah to be in
the lineup to yeah obviously yeah yeah
yeah
um yeah to be what to be to be with
clothes on pay me whatever yeah yeah I
don't care
um 150 bucks 150 bags I think I'd do it
for I was gonna say 100 but then like I
envisioned 100 Grand maybe 150 because
I'm like all right cool tax free
150k I think I'd do it just to have my
pipe out yeah I'd have to get a semi
but how long can you keep that because
it's not like this like three or four of
a manner yeah yeah and it's not like you
don't know when you're gonna get picked
yeah I'll be nervous I'll be so nervous
which is my tools gonna shrivel up at 40
minutes yeah I'm full too many I'd
probably have a hard time it's gonna be
you know it's actually dread yeah do you
know when you're really nervous and your
your tool is both shriveled and hard at
the same time
[Music]
because it actually it's not even just
it's compact yeah yeah but yeah it's
like a fist
it's hard and Tiny at the same time
basically a button yeah yeah yeah and
your balls get wrinkly
that could never be on National
Television
because I'll tell them don't reveal my
face at the end
they think well she picks you for a date
you have to show your face with my
shovel too
obviously they flip the ticket you have
your guards on it yeah nah I'll just
come out like that they could never know
it was me oh no ah no maybe 150 yeah I
don't think that's priceless yeah it's
not enough yeah I don't think there is
enough money because I know I'm gonna be
nervous because I'll be overthinking the
whole thing oh thanks yeah I'll be yeah
yeah yeah yeah because it's dread yeah
yeah I don't know because you'll see me
on there like this you know the
silhouette you'll see me on there please
literally please
please if there's any time you're going
to listen to me today's the day yeah fam
please they're setting up the whole
thing and I can feel myself shriveling
yeah and then you'll just see all the
men standing there and then there's one
brain like please please please please
fapping away please please grow please
go please
side key you gotta be mentally you gotta
be mentally strong it's too much bro I
couldn't yeah I don't know it'd have to
be a meal then it'd have to be something
that you don't need to see me again yeah
yeah yeah yeah because I would change
locations yeah yeah 100 done with this
and then I'd have to sleep with anyone
who cussed me yeah do you know what I
mean yeah because you need to know
what's really about you don't know you
don't really know what I'm about what
the TV show is not what's real yeah yeah
yeah it changes is the shape and it
changes the size of your own stuff yeah
yeah let me show you the real time let
me show you the routine because that was
not an accurate yeah I need every I need
to bang enough girls so that the whole
world knows yeah that what you saw on TV
is not the general consensus yeah yeah
100 even the team that put me for the
date needs to know facts facts REM how
much how much can you go on the shop
where
yeah
150 150. Alice
yeah yeah
I said Infinity by the end of it so how
much how much would you charge bro
you do for a hundred bucks
say less
yeah
you'll get your tool out what's just
saying anyway
we're here
you know exactly what I mean bro what's
your two saying Magic
and this is going so red well big man
said what's your two saying for real
yeah is it like
rims on the floor
like okay cool like unless would you be
work would you okay if you went on naked
exactly would you be concerned just say
that
yeah about public opinion
um remember you're not hard
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah but Sammy your your calm
are you circumcised or no
say less do you have a turtlenecking or
is it is it
it's normal
say less say left foot man on the spot
all right say let's say let's say less
jokes come all right I would probably do
it for
again I'm thinking because the more I
think about trying to get a semi whilst
I'm on live TV the more I'll shrivel up
yeah oh yeah yeah so would have it would
have to be seven figures because like
you said I'd have to move country I'd
have to be no not even country I'd move
continents yeah yeah because they can't
televise this anywhere else yeah I need
to know that no one in this country's
seen it yeah facts facts facts or
something or New Zealand yeah I'll keep
it somewhere there yeah I'll live lavish
but anyway say less jeez that's vile it
is that's vile
um right I've got a question for you
gang and the funny thing is I don't even
remember what the question was I wrote
down a
this is a question someone sent it to me
it's okay right so someone breaks into
your house while you're taking a [__]
do you wipe first or no
question and a half fam question and a
half
hmm I'm trying to think about my current
yacht setup
um actually yes I would wipe I I
wouldn't wipe properly but I'll take a
first one yeah
it depends on the type of [__] I've
taken as well right okay cool bear in
mind that's a huge bearing in mind this
is yours so you live in an apartment
right yeah yeah my layout are you in the
ensuite are you in I'm in my one
yeah they've got to cover some ground to
get to you yeah so you're there yeah
you're you're on Tick Tock you're you're
busting a doo-doo yeah
and it's Turtle heading so it's not even
all the way out so I'm like yeah yeah
you're pushing you're actively pushing
yeah and you hear bang someone kicks the
door it swings into what's the loudest
bang you've ever heard and it's followed
by like they're running and
they don't hesitate it's bang and
they're right there's multiple Footsteps
in there are you telling me you're
grabbing tissue
[Laughter]
no
considering I'm pushing I think the Fear
Factor will take it back we'll suck it
back in yeah yeah but you've you've
still got like a cake yeah your cake
I've got fudge down here yeah yeah I've
got Barefoot man yeah yeah yeah so yeah
well in that moment think of just Prime
picture a reaction
because you're not thinking straight I
know it's also mad because it also
depends on
it also depends on whether I'm about to
shower after that [__] oh because if I
am because your ass naked stalkers or
I've just got boxes okay in this one no
no it's middle of the day you just
you've got your clothes okay yeah yeah
shorts uh wife beater and whatnot
how do I wipe
I don't think I could I think the Fear
Factor will kick because I've never
heard that noise before winter is scared
when you said multiple footsteps I've
never been here today I've never been so
fat
I promise you in your yard especially I
think my initial reaction
this is you know it's funny do you know
how you know I'm a [__]
do you know how you know I'm a [__]
because I said she's going through my
head all I can imagine is Tom I think
what I would do I mean I've got time I'm
in the attic
I've got time to wipe and wash my hands
and try to see what it does I just see
what's going on yeah yeah yeah yeah but
um in your yard
in your yard I think I would hop up and
just put one hand on the door oh yeah
and my ass is ah and once there I'm
listening and then I might like yeah do
a standing wipe or something if it's
cake but at first actually to be fair I
don't even think I would I don't even
think I would touch my clothes I think I
would hop up and put all my weight
against that door I'm not confronting
anyone
take what you want and get out
because there's no weapons of choices
there are no weapons of choice you've
got the loobrush and that's it that's it
bro nah
um
I think
I think I would still I would do I would
do one I think I'll do one I'd have to
do one my hands will shake oh drop I'll
go to reach the toilet I will drop on
the whole thing yeah I'll panic I will
just jump up and push the door as hard
as I can multiple footsteps no that that
was scary literally what you said all
those years ago do what you want just
don't kill me just don't kill facts
both hands on the door push it as hard
as I can ass chicks are out
exposed I'm vulnerable as hell yeah my
[__] is by my ankles I'll push it all my
way against the door even though no
one's pushing back and say and wait
until I know they're in airshow do
whatever you want just don't kill me
oh to me I probably wouldn't even shower
I would just hold it there and breathe
yeah yeah yeah just wait yeah just wait
that's all you can because hopefully
they don't come in here I would pray bro
I would pray that I'm coming there
that will scare everything out of me and
the maddest thing is I wouldn't know who
to tell after this happened
of course what what am I telling Fiverr
what am I telling the things they're
just broken and I'm like where were you
I was in the house then up in the toilet
Ben up in the toilet I was taking a [__]
they ran up in the yard I've never heard
so many footsteps I've never heard
footsteps like that they came in here
dare me they came in here with intent
with intent and a purpose yeah they knew
where they were going and what they were
looking for
that would do bits to my psyche that
would do bits to my side oh I'd never
take a [__] again oh not in my yard I
would have to move out yeah you can't
stay I can't because they know where I'm
at yeah because you live in an apartment
yeah yeah so if they're if they're
busting in there then they can busting
anywhere [__] you live on like the fifth
floor some [__] yeah yeah no way in my
yard I'm I'm free for the taking yeah
I've got the nicest house on a [__]
Street yeah yeah I'm First Choice
factual you are you are oh God speaking
of um remember we spoke about or I spoke
about my pastor situation when we were
90s babies
okay give for those who didn't watch the
knights so cool yeah context right so I
had ordered stuff for the um
I had a staycation last week um and we
had to wear uh White Gardens so I bought
some um white trousers to come to my
yard but I went to the rug yard I live
in an apartment and there were houses as
well on the same street so instead of it
going to my apartment house it went to
obviously the house house the
correspondent the corresponding number
the correspondent number on on that
street which was a house
um and obviously I got the email saying
oh it has been successfully delivered
and I saw the doormat and the picture I
was like obviously it's not my yard and
at least I know where I can go to if I
need to try and get it so the day after
I went there knock knock no one answered
I think I went to the gym came back
knocked again so I was in change of
clothes
no one answered I was like cool family
went on 90s and I said the thing I was
like if I get back from this thing and I
knock and they don't answer I just have
to charge it to the game because it just
is white there's nothing I can do
anymore they're not answering enough to
charge the game yeah so I think was it
the morning of
um
a few days I can't remember what day it
was but a few days ago as you do wake up
on your phone check your DMs well
whatever just do socials I went to my
requests
pack of requests I was like what's going
on what is going on and I opened one it
says hi for that I don't know if you
know but there is a group chat
and you have been a Hot Topic since last
week I sat up James I sat up no no no no
no no no no I've been Hot Topics since
last week I sat up in bed I was like let
me see wild one I couldn't read I sat up
I gotta see you read that for the first
time I was petrified I was petrified I
know you were I was like what's going on
but she didn't give me context so I
scrolled through went to another DM she
gave me screenshots of the group chat
um but my man says what do you mean
another DM so I got bear DMS from the
same thing I got bad here from different
people about the same situation and
they're all in the group chat yes DM in
you yes bro yes bro it was mad to me
no I don't think you might understand I
felt so unsafe because people just know
me now yeah yeah I just know where I'm
at oh God so unsafe anyway
oh my God anyway I will be crying I
would have bailed you immediately how
you came down until now I do not know
are the bells you immediately I was
saving it for the show [__] you know oh
so yeah
screenshots now the my man said has
anyone does anyone know who this guy is
he was knocking on my door
um and my wife I didn't want my wife to
answer blah blah blah because and then
people were like oh someone said oh I
think he's X I can't remember what you
said maybe like someone that works in
the area I can't remember what he said
and then other people like has he done
anything is he just knocking like it was
clear I was knocking during the day
because he put screenshots of the the
ring door so I'm in the group chat my
face context context remember I said I
went pre-gym and post gym and I changed
both pictures were in that [__] I was
livid yeah so they put both of my
outfits in the group chat so I'm going
to read some of the stuff that it found
it what I didn't love about is that they
were riding for me oh so they were
riding for me they these are doing God's
work oh and I was just in the background
so this is a neighborhood watch Team
it's a neighborhood watch that you just
were never invited thank God I wasn't
invited because I don't like things
yeah I couldn't I couldn't have been
privy to this information man said does
anyone know who this is bro look at my
mug
what
or if he's knocked on anyone else's door
I went straight to his door he's a
racist he's a racist that's the other
one literally same day next match as
well you're just that's you're Spiderman
I'm just like this guy just turned up
again in different clothes
bro just turn up again in different
clothes I don't want my wife to open the
door
to me what I think about it that way if
I was in his shoes I'd be like this is a
bit sauce oh 100 let's change clothes
not knocked in anyone else's door but
mine I'm not in my wife is in babes
don't answer the door yeah I don't know
why it could fax but at the same time
you've accepted a package
that didn't have your name on it you
should be expecting someone who looks
like a foo head to knock on the door at
some point factual factual but
um someone obviously there's bad people
in the chat it's so important oh he
looks like the guy from the Pod then he
put um one of our fingers in there and
baby we're like oh I think it's him I
think it's him I think it's him and then
one of the chicks was like
people usually people usually post
trainers who um display she wrote she
basically wrote a long ass paragraph to
say you're racist no to say yeah that
the my man's racist and you shouldn't be
doing unconscious biases and blah blah
blah he could be very innocent the man
replied I don't have time to read your
essay and I don't need to justify
anything to you
can double tap a message and leave an
emoji yeah they put the sick emoji and
thumbs down
in the neighborhood watch group chat I
don't have time to adjust to myself to
justify myself to you this is my wife's
life we're talking about I don't care
who he is clothes or no clothes
I've got my kids to protect
call me whatever you want that was so
that was so family to protect even
though I knew the whole thing was about
me that bit made me laugh bro that broke
the ice of the whole thing I can imagine
I can imagine I don't have time to read
your essay my wife's life is on the line
these came very different gums bro that
he would have typed that song bro he's
here again
please tell me who he was and who what
he wants anyway follow even furthermore
obviously people had listened to
it was just by luck that we well I spoke
about that night on 90s because
obviously that came out when ours came
out on Monday and then people listen to
nice and they posted that in the group
chat wow oh so the reason why he came
over because you had these garments and
not any suspicious thing they didn't
send me an exclusions because I think he
didn't reply
but I think the day after that or maybe
a few days after after the gym again I
went down the road
and I knocked on the door but I know
it's this time because after they've
sent you this after they said all of
this yeah
I had time to gather my thoughts
oh my horse racing figure out my eyes
racing you have no idea
please continue I've never been so
invested in anything you [__] said
please continue [__] so I was knocking
on the door the car wasn't there because
it was a black car that was there before
both times and now now nothing was I was
knocking knocking knocking
I was like damn maybe not in because
obviously the car's not there but I
noticed once I was walking obviously you
know the road the long road before I
Buster left I was walking down I noticed
there were people behind me like a few
steps behind it was a mum and three kids
I was like I didn't think anything of it
but I saw it so when I knock knocks no
one was no one answered nothing happened
I was like all right maybe I'll just go
turn around and go home because I knew
it was you save me on as soon as I
turned around she was there waiting with
that pram oh God it was her yard oh God
she was the wife oh and she was
petrified I bet she was in my opinion my
assumption was in that moment first of
all well
okay I'm gonna let you finish yeah carry
on in my assumption in that moment is or
was
she's not in the group chat only the
husband is because she hasn't got time
to do she's got kids to look after this
is why I didn't she didn't this is why I
didn't currently speaking deal with that
yeah so she doesn't know that I'm privy
to the information that the rest of us
know yeah yeah she's just seen the same
brother again yeah yeah and she's got
kids with her yeah oh yeah so when I was
like oh do you live here she was like
yes I was like oh I explained the story
about package blah blah blah and the
maddest thing was I was looking for the
picture because I was going to like oh
wait on my email but I realized it was a
screenshot that Bella sent to me I
couldn't find it so it made it seem as
if I was a [__] liar oh I see what
you said waiting for me oh waiting for
me to show me the evidence then I
finally remembered oh [__] it's a
screenshot I showed her the picture I
was like it said it's been delivered
here I've seen the the picture the
picture exactly exactly the same thing
yeah yeah I've been knocking for days
I specifically said to her I was the one
that came a few days ago I don't know if
you saw the blah blah but yeah there was
nothing there and she said
oh he the guy came but it was like
he asked always this the yard of me and
she said oh no and I was like but why
does it say it got delivered then he
said but she said they had a
conversation her and the delivery driver
saying oh this is in the yard this is
not the yard so so take it or take it
back and I was like so did he take it
back and she said yes so he just took a
picture of it anyway he took a picture
so my assumption is
he had taken a pitch I said it was
delivered knocked and then wanted to
give it and then this conversation
happened
or she's a liar she's a liar
and the husband's wearing the gums now
as we speak whilst he's listening to
this he's wearing the gums as we speak
so I've charged it to the game bro I've
just charged it to the game wow so I am
the more I think about the fact that my
face was in that group chat twice in two
different gobs on the same day the less
I want to be involved oh facts so yeah
if he's got it have it if have it if you
haven't got it here's what it is I've
charged mad bro it was the wildest
exchange of events
roller coaster yeah
sharing that if it wasn't for the fact
that we spoke about it or I spoke about
our 90s babies wow only God knows what
they said I would have been
only God knows what they said I would
have been man said I ain't got time to
read this [__] my wife's Life song I
know what you're accusing me of but I
don't want to hear it
I don't care he said I don't care
I'm glad they were riding for you I'm
glad they were [__] writing yeah they
you lot you know who you are you did
God's work thank you that's pain
God lucky you're famous bro otherwise
the same group chat would have happened
yeah yeah yeah yeah you'd have been
ignored by everyone every in the
neighborhood
I would have been shunned for no reason
no reason yeah it was mad bro okay fair
enough mad Twist of events interesting
interest what are you gonna ask or say
what I was going to say is
um
how is it that she's terrified when all
of this has happened how is it that her
how is it that her man hasn't told her
yeah by the way the group chat said this
guy is here because he he knows he's in
the wrong yeah yeah yeah he doesn't want
to bait himself my assumption is he
thought I was gonna he hoped he would be
in one and not the next time yeah yeah
yeah oh he prayed for it yeah yeah fair
enough
um okay cool fair enough uh it's a shame
it's a weird one now because if they
didn't have your package then
is things are somewhat justifiable facts
facts his concerns are somewhat
justifiable if you've done another
package
um but then again yeah um it's a weird
one it is a weird one damn bro yeah man
why alternative events that is why
alternative events and it was such quick
succession because I had no intention of
speaking about it
on 90s maybe yeah I can imagine no
intention especially on someone else's
car I had no intention I don't even know
how that came about I can't remember how
it came about either yeah wow we yeah
bro I couldn't imagine haifu had this is
what's going on you've been in a group
chat for a week
That's The Truman Show thing bro I was
getting DMs
oh it was scary oh it sounds scary I've
never felt someone safe facts bro I
never felt someone safe never felt
something
oh it was mad to me yeah that's so cool
that's such a cool story yeah they you
man you wrote for me thank you
that's crazy yeah bro it was mad it was
mad Fair Play Okay cool so to finish up
we've got tweets of the week yeah oh
yeah
right you start us off I really I'm off
trying to catch trying to catch me
cheating knowing you can't pay bills on
your own is crazy to me
when they say that's facts it is some
may say that's facts that is jeez when
you can't pay bills in your home
that's crazy
right he said it's crazy to me that is
crazy crazy to me all right this one is
similar to that yeah in a way fam
when a woman cheats it hurts a man's
Soul so bad he's been asking dumb [__]
like did you moan did he hit it from the
back
those are the questions I'd be asking
the thing is I don't think I can bring
myself to ask those questions because I
don't want to know that yeah that's the
thing because that's why if I ever got
cheated on I can't take you back yeah no
matter how much I love you and I want to
take you back and I believe that you're
sorry yeah that tweet right there is the
sole reason I can't take you back yeah
yeah because I need to know and I don't
want to know at the same time I don't
want to hear it I needed a bagel I don't
want to hear what you have to say I
don't want to hear what you have to say
I'll be pulling my hair out bro because
like literally
did how many positions did you do did
you moan that's a question did you moan
did you moan bro did he flip you over
did he choke you out
when it slipped out to help him put it
back in when it sit down did you help
him put it back in that that were you
thinking about me at all in this
situation
you suck him off
his dick's been in your mouth
that's how I know you hate me yeah yeah
yeah yeah you don't love me at all
x-man's tall in your mouth yeah her lips
you every day bro yes I know you never
loved me
next man's tool in your mouth yeah
because like when if
the only way a man can truly accept it
and take you back is if he eventually
like the reason he's asking he needs to
know it was somewhat non-consensual
Jeremy he can't hear yeah you asked for
this yeah
we can't hear that you asked for this
yeah because I need to console you off
yeah yeah yeah that's the only way I can
take it back into my arms
[__] there's an element of this that
wasn't considered yeah yeah to get to
the bottom of it because he couldn't be
my wife it couldn't be my wife yeah and
there's no way you can turn to me and be
like I'm sorry I won't do it again
because his tool was in your in your
throat your gob
this is a um
this is a 200 block
when my boyfriend broke up with me I
blocked everyone except him and
photoshopped a boot on my leg so he
would text me and ask me if I was okay
and he didn't reply
so what happened if you are so what
would happen if you asked you to meet up
reply I would have broken my leg
[Laughter]
wow that's commitment fam the heart will
make you do anything yeah the heart will
make you do anything ain't that the
truth fam the heart never your heart
does not have your best interests
it does not have your best interest in
mind yeah it does whatever it wants yeah
yeah yeah it's just no passion
by any means necessary
wow whichever way the wind takes it
power it's crazy this one sweet I mean
this is a deep back and forth DMV
so
first DM
if you could be any flavor of ice cream
what would you be and why reply
rocky road because I've only all right
rocky road because I've been going
through it LOL what about you Ed
three days later was I the wrong kind of
ice cream
fam three days later said
response I thought we were flirting was
I the wrong kind of ice cream man red
rocky road has said swipe left
rocky road because I've been going
through it
yeah I don't need that yeah hilarious
oh tell me something sexy facts I want
to hear mango it's like sorbet
yeah yeah give me a little passion fruit
salad yeah yeah yeah we can we can act
on him I said Rocky Road because I'm
going through it
Bay
are you still there I thought we were
flirting I created a fake account and
started chatting with my hubby he just
told me my wife died three years ago
reply to her own sweep I posted an
update about it on my Twitter feed for
people to think that people don't think
I'm married okay now bro
my wife died three years ago I man's
playing off widower not even single yeah
widower
come scoop me yeah yeah yeah I'm hurting
scoop me I ain't found love since that's
crazy she's playing Chester she created
a failure counter chat to me she's
playing chess yeah she is she is she is
when I said [__] tighter than your mama
lips when she say put that [__] back
put this a dick
that's when you get them wrinkles yeah
yeah
wow that's jokes
the sex spots on IG been going hard and
liking all of my stories and I
appreciate the support
fact let me guess oh many random follows
and likes is unbelievable
imagine being on vacation with a guy and
he pinches his nose before jumping into
the pool
fam allow me in it
if I don't want to breathe water I'm I'm
within my right
this
yeah
that double breath it's the worst is
when you've like you've jumped in or
whatever and you it's deeper than you
think oh of course you're swimming up
and you take that first breath you're a
mess yeah you are you are you are you
are you are you are and you love your
life is just looking at you dreads and
the thing is as well you know you have
to if you're holding your nose you have
to do a pencil dive
you're you're like this as well oh
and you have to Tippy Toe and just and
just let it take you and if you're a
waste man once you go in it bananas yeah
yeah yeah you're a waste man yeah yeah
yeah that's hilarious
cardi B got street thugs in the club
screaming a long ass weave it be
tickling my ass crack
oh bro cardi B can make me sing anything
bro She Bangs bro doesn't see just cardi
and Nicki Minaj at a point
like you I would say like our unit is
just after uni as well yeah yeah cardi
B's got the streets man
I often think about the time I slash my
ex's tires and the new guy came out and
changed it straight away I cried
watching from the bushes
that's a that's a man that is that's a
man right away I'm a boy
man was hiding in the bushes just like
slashing tires said you [__] you [__]
you [__] and I knew man's just just
built and strong just said let me handle
that change the tire straight away
I couldn't be faced with that level of
inadequacy
inadequacy I'm in a bush yeah yeah yeah
I'm hiding in a bush that's Peak that's
very Peak yeah this is a um tweet and a
quick tweet
you guys pray I do well on this test I'm
about to take
quote tweet I see you guys didn't pray
at all
[Laughter]
oh that was making my back hurt lift it
now that's funny oh Jesus
oh God Drake really showed a girl he was
dating his music and she told that guy
to put on ludicrous instead I would have
been heated too do you remember that
track yes I do what's it called it was
on um
I don't remember what it was on it's on
I'm pretty sure it's on care package
good memory what's the song called
it's called I can't remember I can't
remember
um
yeah oh God how about now yeah yeah how
about now played
do you guys be knowing that their dick
is small quote sweet
I knew my [__] was small when I whipped
it out and she tried to scissor me
foreign
that's
I wouldn't know I would I wouldn't know
I wouldn't know I wouldn't know I'd
panic
don't make it worse yeah
it would get smaller it should be like
gay
and these actually rub it wow oh my
that's when man found out his [__] was
small
let's try to see them it's a friction
thing because you're not penetrating
nothing you're not penetrating a thing
oh God
I'm still trying to figure out how I'm
gonna be at four places at once on
February the 14th
yo fat 14 5 dogs on the ropes
because there's no experience there
really isn't there either with me
you need to clear your roster yeah yeah
a week ahead of time yep yep yep yep
that's hilarious oh God
um guys say anything for the coochie
this man asked me what type of guy I
like and I said I like guys that shut
the [__] up and he said yeah yeah I
don't even talk like that for real
wow I don't even talk like that for real
first of all I can never ask anything
what kind of guys you like I like guys
you shut the [__] up
what would you say to me what's going on
I like guys who shut the [__] up
and you're just there yeah yeah yeah I
hate talking I'm much real still yeah
I'm a silent baby
I'm not asking any Chick what your type
of guy is yeah of course what do you
mean I'm right here yeah
my husband doesn't my husband doesn't
believe in Lube or foreplay he just
sticks it in dry I have to allow a
little bit of we onto him so he doesn't
feel like something's shoving like
someone's shoving a raw parsnip inside
of me he thinks he's getting me wet all
by himself
I don't know about that one that one
sounds a bit
my yeah sounds very techy as well
it sounds very technical
who's got their bladder on tap like that
that's what I was thinking
that's what I was thinking it's mad
I'm on my burner commenting thank you
for normalizing nose hair on his
girlfriend's tick tock
wow women are dark yeah women are
[__] bro thank you for normalizing
wow wow you absolute [__]
oh my God whenever a man is in love
you're right she's the strongest person
I've ever known on his birthday post to
her and it's like what did you do to her
Kyle
she's the strongest person I've ever
known I don't know who else can deal
with that
she's gone through the Ring of her he
has gone through the ringer for me
that's hilarious Jesus oh okay I've got
um I think it's the last one
oh my boyfriend and I my boyfriend and I
made a list of people we could have sex
with if we got the chance he chose
Margot Robbie Charlize Theron and
Scarlett Johansson I chose my daughter's
biology teacher the Barista at Starbucks
and his younger brother
I'll smack her in immediately I'll smack
her and I know what game you're trying
to play immediately you're a hawk just
say it
if you don't tell me my younger brother
could never be on that list
oh it's fisticuffs it's festy cars the
barista
that's just something yeah that's a guy
that's just anybody that's a medium guy
our daughter's teacher
rap I thought we were doing that fancy I
didn't know if you wanted to [__] the
people that you are close to right now
yeah yeah just civilians basically
anyone but your mind
ah God that's right that's not train
thing all over it yes bro train train
train train Emoji Jesus right guys that
was um that was a penguin it was a
healthy one thank you as always uh we're
gonna leave you here and we will catch
you on patreon on Thursday
and yeah guys that's all we have to say
love love love
[Music]